well then the number one word is lazy
right so your teachers thinks you're
slow your parents think you're lazy and
this is something that is uniquely true
for most kids like me who grew up with
dyslexia or ADHD or any type of
neurodiversity your parents just think
that you don't care what you're about to
hear is an interview between me and
Cliff Weitzman who is a friend of mine
Cliff is one of the most inspiring
people that I've ever met I believe that
I could do anything when you're a kid
you keep telling yourself that you can
do these things and at a certain point
most people believe that actually they
can't that just never happened to me he
is the founder and CEO of speechify
which is an app that helps basically
convert the internet into audiobooks
Cliff has dyslexia and in his past he
was unable to read and is still
basically unable to read and so ended up
building speechify as a way of helping
himself get through school and college
and university we talk a little bit
about his background there and how that
affected his experiences growing up my
younger brother Tyler tell himself how
to build iPhone apps so we worked on it
together Tyler did most of the work and
I did some but while I was in college I
kept teaching myself more and more so
that I could fix this program then I
built a tool that would parse PDFs for
me so I could take 300 Page PDF for my
history class and turn it into a two
hour audiobook and then go work out and
just finish the PDF Cliff is also
incredibly intentional about the
relationship in his life and about
giving love and compassion putting Good
Vibes out there into the world and so in
the second half of the conversation we
talk a lot about his approach to
relationships how he just randomly cold
emails and messages people and says hey
do you want to be my friend and then
somehow hangs out with them I met Amar
and Thomas and Matt from yes Theory or
Logan or Jimmy and I just would study
how they created content and then I
gotta go to creating content and we talk
a lot about this balance between kind of
striving for success and also investing
in relationships just put good energy
into the world and if you do that good
things happen
at the moment according to the YouTube
analytics 81 of you who are watching
this on YouTube have not yet hit the
Subscribe button and so if you're for
example in the now 81 of people who are
watching this on YouTube but who are not
subscribed to the channel I would love
it if you could do so and would be
awesome to get that number down to 50
and it would be cool to get like 50 50
sub non-sub ratio just just for fun
Cliff thank you so much for being on the
podcast
this is it's cool doing this like
actually in person because I remember
the first time we we were we got
introduced through Valentin and did like
a live streamy type thing and you were
on mine and my brother's podcast talking
about juntos and stuff
um so so much so much to talk about
let's start
um by rewinding back to Childhood and
the reading situation so what was going
on in your childhood with with the whole
struggling to read stuff and I guess
we'll track your life story over time
and get to the present day and I'm sure
at some point we'll break it and do a
part two because there's so much to dive
into sounds fun yes I think the first
time we did our first interview
it was the very beginning of covid and I
was sitting on a bench press that I just
installed in my apartment yes uh because
we had I think five of us living in a
one bedroom apartment in La at the time
But to answer your question so I grew up
in Israel I moved to the U.S when I was
13 and first second third fourth grade I
had a really tough time learning how to
read
um I have four younger siblings who are
very sharp my sister speaks seven
languages my brother started coding when
he was eight and then skipped four and a
half years of math in high school uh you
know build 47 apps by the time he was 17
did his Master's in AI Stanford and I
couldn't figure out how to spell my last
name and I wanted to read really really
badly but I would fall asleep inside of
books all the time
and So eventually my dad was like okay
there's no way he's like this lazy
um
and he started reading to me
and my dad has a very deep voice so
every night I'd fall asleep listening to
my dad reading Harry Potter
and he would record himself with
cassette tapes and I just love this so
much I would listen to them over and
over again and when I moved to the US
when I was 13 I didn't speak English
and I found the Harry Potter audiobook
set and so I listened to that thing 22
times in a row and that's how I learned
English
and I fell in love with audiobooks So I
listened to about 100 audiobooks a week
sorry a year I also know about 100
audiobooks a year and I've done that for
the last 16 years or so and it doesn't
matter if it's sci-fi or fantasy or
philosophy or theology or politics or
economics I'm just obsessed with
listening and in the beginning I would
listen to like 0.75 X speed because I
literally didn't speak English
and then you know I practiced then I got
the 1X speed and then 1.25 and then 1.5
and 2x
um and continue from there
so you okay so you moved to the US from
Israel h13
um what what was happening around the
time of the move like why did you why
did your family move
um so we had moved for a very brief
period outside of Israel earlier and we
had wanted to move to the US but like it
didn't work out for Visa reasons
and my parents were like hey this seems
like a fun adventure and my dad has this
philosophy you know if you write a book
in Hebrew seven million people can read
it if you do it in English seven billion
can and they saw it as one of the
biggest ways that they could open up the
world to us and give us opportunities
and so my parents did a really really
good job raising us um they're really
the
the best example of parenting I've
actually come across
um and so they included us on all the
big decisions so I remember they sat us
down and they're like hey
would you guys be interested in going on
an adventure like yeah let's go on an
adventure and so we all decided that we
wanted to move to the United States and
so when I got here it was really tough
because the culture in the US is
slightly different than the culture in
Israel
like I spoke with a heaviest lady accent
like nobody understood what I was saying
um and
I was a really small kid too like I was
five two freshman year five three
sophomore year like literally I have a
driver's license where I'm 16 and I
weigh like 110 pounds
um
and when I moved here I'm super dyslexic
so I spent all this time learning how to
read in Hebrew and then I had to relearn
how to read but in English but because I
signed up for this move I was really
motivated
um and it didn't matter if it was like
eighth grade where I was like failing my
history class and there was no like
audiobooks for the textbook so I would
like go online and Google and I'd like
try to hack together some sort of
audiobook that I could listen to
um and actually ended up I would go to
my teachers and I would ask hey like
I'll just be real with you there's
there's no way I'm going to be able to
read this chapter or do the outline that
you're assigned is it okay if I come to
class like 15 minutes early and verbally
summarize the chapter to you
and surprisingly many teachers said yes
um and so going into High School my mom
literally had to read my summer reading
books to me because I couldn't do them
myself even going into college
um we had this book called sons of
Providence and I spent all summer trying
to read it I didn't want to be the one
kid who shows up not having done the
summer reading before his like fancy Ivy
League school
and I read about half and so my mom had
to read the rest of it and she worked
and she didn't have time to read all of
it shared maybe another 25 and so I was
I was stuck and so the only thing that I
did the only thing I could do which is
like I built this text-to-speech
software that would read the book into
my iPhone overnight and then I listened
to that on the planet it worked and then
you know I used the version of that
throughout College
um but yeah like I was very very very
motivated to learn how to read and to
like figure out English and succeed in
school when I was young so having having
dyslexia like what is that like like
when you when you see words on a page
like how would you try and describe it
to someone who did yeah yeah so most
people
visualize dyslexia as like the words
flipping around or jumping or flipping
that's not what it's actually like
um the best description I've ever been
able to come up with is reading a
sentence takes me as much energy and
brain power as most people take to do a
long division equation in their head so
that means that it takes a long time to
read a sentence and it's very energy
fatiguing so if I wanted to read a page
that's like doing 20 multiplications all
in a row but like
2400 divided by like 13. you know 5 800
divided by 72. and
you know you'd be tired after doing that
now I imagine doing it for a chapter
like you'd be asleep so literally this
was my problem I would I I dedicated
every school break that I had when I was
young like literally third grade and
upwards to trying to learn how to read
and I would get woken up by Librarians
in the public library basically on a
daily basis
um but I was really motivated because I
really admired my dad my dad is a lawyer
and I want him to be proud of me and in
my head I was very ambitious from a very
young age
um I think about as like I have this
fire in my chest that if it was to open
it would like bounce off the walls
um and I was like look I won't be a
billionaire I won't be president I won't
be a pop star I won't be any of these
things I want to be if I don't know how
to read so I have to figure out how to
read and so I just I worked on it
um
and then
so number one it's time like everything
just takes a lot longer when reading is
involved number two it's it's
draining
and number three you know spelling is
difficult you know I mix up my left and
rights it's hard for me to remember
names uh the scientific backing behind
dyslexia it's there's no conclusive one
answer but here's the best one that I've
understood reading a bunch of PhD papers
about it there's these things in a brand
called mini columns and they're
responsible for sharing information if
you are a normal person you have normal
length mini columns that are normally
distributed if you're artistic
interestly interestingly you have
shorter mini columns that are closer
together if you are dyslexic you have
longer mini columns that are further
apart and so people who are savants
they're very good at specific small
tasks short-term memory people with
dyslexia have bad short-term memory and
most importantly they have bad what's
called phonemic awareness and so reading
is challenging and actually dyslexia is
not a reading disability it's a decoding
disability so if you look at the word
like
house house you need to break down the
phonemes and understand them it's like a
puzzle I'm bad at this so in college
when I'd walk around with friends like
my girlfriend in college knew every
single street name I didn't know a
single street name because when she
looked at the signs her eyes immediately
told her what that was but I would need
to dedicate energy to reading that word
it's like being a long division thing
and you then yeah how are you going to
remember that exactly but if I see a
picture of a guitar or a house like it's
like an emoji a dog Emoji I know what it
is
um yeah so that's how dyslexia impacts
me
when did you figure out that you had
dyslexia yeah versus I'm just dumb or
can't read or you know the other things
you might have told yourself
well then the number one word is lazy
right so your teacher thinks you're slow
your parents think you're lazy and this
is something that is uniquely true for
most kids like me who grew up with
dyslexia or ADHD or any type of
neurodiversity your parents just think
that you don't care but I really cared
and so in preschool uh I'm I'm very
musical right actually the best example
of you know what is it like to be
dyslexia Search up the song or read to
you by Cliff Weitzman and you'll find it
on Spotify
um
so I was I was good at all the plays and
I was good at Art and I was good at
acting
and you know a lot of kids learned how
to read a little bit before first grade
my parents couldn't get me to learn I
was like oh it's fine but he'll learn it
in first grade but then that didn't
happen
and that didn't happen in second grade
either and my dad started to get really
mad at me because he was like Cliff like
why are you not paying attention like
why are you so lazy why don't you care
and I was like do you care
um
and yeah over time we just kept working
at it
you mentioned that you were quite
ambitious growing up and he said
president and billionaire and pop star
what's what's going on there
um
you know I don't know where this even
happened but like from the moment I
remember having conscious thought maybe
four and a half years old
I believed that I could do anything like
I thought I was a superhero I believed I
could do a backflip I believe they could
do a front flip I believe that I could
be in the Olympics I believe that I
could be you know I listened to someone
on the radio I was like oh I can do that
and so I signed up for like a singing
dancing troupe and by the time I was 12
I was performing a TV in Israel
um and you know I believe that I could
be like prime minister of Israel so I
was like cool I'm going to be a
billionaire prime minister and a pop
star all at the same time
um and
you know when you're a kid you keep
telling yourself that you can do these
things
and at a certain point most people
believe that actually they can't
that just never happened to me like
everything I still dream constantly like
I live
80 of my life daydreaming about the
future
okay so you move to the US you taught
yourself English through basically Harry
Potter audiobooks The Stephen Fry ones
the jibnea ones
so in the United States this incredible
Shakespearean actor named Jim Dale does
all the Harry Potter narration oh it's
actually as a result of like some rights
issues uh audiobook company actually own
the Masters they don't own audio rights
uh and so Stephen Fry is an American uh
dude who narrates the audiobooks for
Harry Potter in Britain
oh interesting
um and then you go to university in UL
college and you went to Brown yes
what did you study I studied Renewable
Energy Engineering so it's a mix of
physics engineering computer science
yeah Brown is a very interesting spot
because you can make your own major
um so I invented my major at the time I
thought that renewable energy would be
the field that would grow the most over
the next 50 years and
um basically I built like solar cells
and nuclear reactors and like studied
Hydro energy but down the street from
Brown is a place called RISD the Rhode
Island
um
design Institute and it's the number one
design school in the world actually both
founders of Airbnb went to RISD so I
took a lot of industrial design and
graphic design courses at RISD and I
took classes in like philosophy and
um you know biotechnology and you know
medicine Etc because
I just love learning and so I basically
like
Brown also doesn't require you to take
any requirements with the exception of
two classes that have to do something
with writing during the 32 courses that
you take
and so I just refused to take
prerequisites I would email professors
and I would get them to let me take the
class I remember
I had one semester where two of my
classes I was missing six or seven
prerequisites to be in it it was like
Masters level courses and I was just
yeah I'll figure it out and then I just
did them and so I learned a lot it was
like my two weeks in my cheeks started I
heard from smiling so much it was like
the best experience of my life okay
um and and you said that before you got
there you you built a text-to-speech
thing to be able to read the pre the the
pre-reading that's right how how did you
just build a text-to-speech that like
were you dabbling with coding and stuff
when you were younger like what was the
story there yeah so my younger brother
Tyler is 18 months younger than me
him and my sister were in the gifted
program every single year
um when we were growing up I didn't get
in then they both got into Exeter which
is the number one high school in the US
Tyler lived in the same dorm that Mark
Zuckerberg was when he was in high
school
Tyler started building Dragon Ball Z
websites with HTML and CSS when he was
in third grade in fifth grade he taught
himself assembly so he could hack my
like RuneScape and MapleStory games and
we moved to the United States we met
people using his hacks
um
where the App Store came out Tyler was
finishing seventh grade he had just
moved to the United States he had just
skipped his first math class and skipped
the class in Spanish even though he
didn't speak Spanish before and he
fished this old Toshiba out of the trash
if it then had like a bunch of viruses
and he cleaned them all up and he turned
it into a Hackintosh and he taught
himself how to build iPhone apps and so
I remember you know we were sharing a
room he'd just be on the computer all
day by the time he was 17 Tyler built 47
iPhone apps
um one was ranked in the top 10 social
networking category of the app store
called black SMS allows you to pass
protect and encrypt your text messages
um so Tyler was coding on my childhood
and I would always try
and I would always fail because I would
misspell the variables and if you code
and you know one variable says you know
house correctly and one says incorrectly
and I can't tell the difference it would
break
so it was ready to moralize him
um right before College I started going
to hackathons and I would try to code
but I sucked but what I would do is I
would hop on a table and I have some
idea and I'd convince people to join my
team
and then
um I would organize people and so I won
the first four out of I I won four out
of the first eight hackathons I did one
was at MIT
um one was by this place called starter
weekend Province and after that I was
like okay I have to learn how to code
and then I just took a bunch of courses
on udemy on how to build iPhone apps and
how to build websites and I would see
how other people did it
um the first version of text-to-speech
for speechify Tyler did most of the work
um I did some of it and Tyler's blind in
his left eye he's asking mannequin his
right eye he does all of his work on
giant projector he now leaves the AIT in
my speechify
um and so we worked on it together Tyler
did most of the work and I did some but
while I was in college I kept teaching
myself more and more so that I could fix
this program because it was oh it was
all it was always break it started as a
Mac app on my computer and it would let
me highlight words like hit a keyboard
shortcut and it would read and most
Americans read a 200 words per minute
um
people will use speechify by default
will listen at 240. most of us can
actually listen faster than we can read
especially today because most people
know they're on YouTube double speed
yeah Tick Tock everything is fast
Instagram double speed WhatsApp messages
podcasts audiobooks
um and then over the first month people
get to listen to 350 words per minute I
listen to everything at 700 words per
minute
um and so I was listening a lot faster
than any other default text-to-speech
readers allowed me to
um but this thing kept breaking so I
kept fixing it and then I took a couple
of classes in computer science
and I kept thinking about it and then I
built a tool that would parse PDS for me
so I could take you know a 300 page PDF
for my history class and turn it into a
two-hour audiobook and that'd go work
out and just finish the PDF
um and I'd have like philosophy classes
with super dense material from like
Aristotle or Nisha or whatever and I
just put it on my computer I click play
I'd listen a little bit slower and I
played like
classical music or like EDM music in the
background with no
um the lyrics at like 30 volume and so
my ADHD brain was like very soothed
because like 70 is on the reading and 30
is on the listening and if you try to
talk to me like ah don't talk to me I'm
like Zone the ad set like that for like
three hours and I didn't take everything
um and that's what I did how's your
comprehension when you're listening that
fast like people always are like oh but
like obviously if you listen to
audiobooks 100 audiobooks you like I I
sometimes mention the stat people like
yeah but like obviously you don't like
actually take any of it in like what's
what's your comprehension like ah 100 so
if I listen to things
I will have most of the memory if I
listen to something three times I'll
have it memorized
um
so here's the thing right I typically
listen and read at the same time
the problem is my reading sucks uh but
speechify highlights words as it goes
and so people with dyslexia
it's a decoding problem more than a
reading problem and so through
speechifier I learned how to sight read
so if I see the word house
500 times a month in random text and
then I hear it at the same time next
time I see house I treat it like an
emoji like I just know that those shapes
mean house it's just most people
dyslexia never get over that Gap to be
able to sight read and so for me I hear
I listen at the same time and so my
retention goes up my comprehension goes
up my understanding goes up I can do it
faster and there's no fatigue
um now when you get good at that you can
start walking around juggling driving
working out cooking whatever and still
listen
um you know when you go to first grade
no one expects you to read well they
expect it to take you know 10 years 12
years before you're actually a really
good reader
you got to practice listening too and so
no one who I've ever met was good at
listening in the first podcast or the
first audiobook they listened to
typically it takes about 10 audiobooks
before you become a fluent listener and
once you become a fluent listener you
can listen faster
you can retain more you can do other
things at the same time and you
understand better and so it's literally
just a function of practice and if you
practice you get really good at it and
then it becomes an absolute superpower
because it can intake the internet
three times faster than everybody else
and you can do it while you're walking
around or doing whatever you want
yeah one of the nice things about this
is that it's it's in a way very passive
practice like all you have to do is like
I I try and tell people this one when
when people hear me listening like if I
have someone in the car and I was
listening to an audiobook on the way to
pick them up and I you know it auto
plays and suddenly it's like and they're
like oh my God is this height is this
how fast you listen and I'm like that's
only 2x I slowed it down because it was
the the climax of both bringer and I
wanted to enjoy it more like
um and I think people find it so hard to
believe that you could actually listen
to something at three times a 3.5 x
speed and actually comprehend it but it
really just is a case of start listening
at one time speed and then 1.1 is not
it's not that bad and then you get used
to that 1.2 it's not that bad and I only
discovered this I think I think it was
two years into listening to audiobooks I
was going I was getting through the
Wheel of Time series and I was like okay
this is getting really slow and then I
tried 1.5 and I was like oh my God
suddenly these slow books I'm way way
more interesting and I just had never
discovered the speed function on Audible
before this and then I was a complete
convert
um yeah if I listen if I listen to less
than 1.5 x speed I want to jump out that
one at the window like I literally I
cannot deal with it even in
conversations with normal humans like
you know when I was single if I would be
a girl and she would speak quickly it's
instantly more attractive because you
can get through so much more material
together
um and it's literally just practice so I
think Malcolm Gladwell in one of his
books I think it's blank he talks about
uh conscious versus you know passive uh
practice and conscious practice you know
most people don't type but 140 words per
minute even though they're typing all
day but if you deliberately deliberate
practice deliberately practice typing
faster you'll get really really fast so
with speechify because it's passive the
computer does the work for you what we
do is there's an automatic speed ramping
algorithm and if you turn it on every
thousand words it increases the speed by
five words per minute whatever is
relevant and so people end up listening
really really fast it's just practice
um one of the things we talked about in
our previous things about I'm sure we're
going to re redo some material is the
criticism that people have of like hey
look man why does life have to go so
fast why can't you like enjoy oh you
know you're one of those toxic
productivity hustle culture Bros that
encourages people to listen and watch
things faster than they should that's
that's not how the artist intended it
like all of those things uh I I imagine
you get those criticisms a lot like
what's your response to this I mean
you're like me
fifty percent of my audible library and
speechify Library are fantasy books I'm
not listening to those things to be
productive man of listening to them
because I love them but I listen to them
at 3x speed
um
imagine every YouTube video how to be
watched at 50 percent speed
no finish the podcast
and so my brain is just adjusted to
intake the same amount of information
but faster
that's it
and so there's a lot of like okay my
favorite piece of art ever is Hamilton
the musical I'm obsessed
um like I've got every word of Hamilton
memorized I listen to Hamilton songs
like a 1.4 when I get the chance
um but part of the reason I like
Hamilton is because it's fast yeah and I
didn't take all of it right but things
that are slow are give me more so what
is true is my brain has just adjusted to
needing more information and by the way
that's true for everybody right it used
to be the 60 of kids in high school
would read books for fun this is like 60
years ago uh now it's less than six
percent
but when you grow up with Instagram and
Tick Tock and YouTube and all the stuff
like your brain needs more information
and even movies it used to be the number
one movie in the world was Gone with the
Wind frankly my dear
I don't give a damn that speed people
would that movie would flop today the
speed is too slow
and so Society is adjusted and if you
adjust with it you reap the rewards hmm
and I guess the the the people who
listen to audiobooks at three times
speed are a bit more ahead of the curve
on sort of speeder processing and like
people are criticizing like the Gen zero
is criticizing that for uh or spending
all the time on watching high-paced
content on Tick Tock exactly and
thinking nothing of it yeah so by the
way if you are able to listen and follow
Tick Tock videos they go really fast if
you're able to listen to a podcast at 2x
speed or listen to an audiobook at 2x
speed
you have a superpower use it
so okay
um someone might be thinking what's the
point of listening to all this stuff if
you don't act on it like surely it's
better to read 10 books a year and
really apply their insights than it is
to read 100 books a year and not apply
their insights again that's another
thing I've heard a lot I've seen a lot
of YouTube comments and stuff whenever I
talk about I can't see this
um okay so here's how I think about
things
all the knowledge in your brain is like
a tree I think of it as a tree of
knowledge when you go to high school in
Middle School you talk to your parents
it builds the bark of your tree when you
go to university and you read more it
builds all this all the the branches and
every book you read is a new Leaf of
information on that train now if you
don't have a spot to let that leaf land
it'll float away so for example if you
know one of the things I did at a
certain point is I listened to the
entire Bible in Hebrew
I did this a couple times
right this doesn't mean anything to you
because you don't have context about
Hebrew
um but even if I told you like one of
the things that were said in the Book of
Numbers like again no relevance so
you're not going to remember this
five days from now
um sometimes it makes sense to re-listen
to a book right so I listen to How to
Win Friends about once a year by Dale
Carnegie because I just think it's a
great book and so there's a lot of books
that I go back to
I can quote most of the book to you but
I still find something new every single
time
because I have that foliage built around
that topic and so recently I've been
reading a ton of books about you know
building brand Performance Marketing
um yeah Austrian economics whatever it
might be
and the more I read in that density the
more I keep
um at the same time I retain most of the
material and so reading like business
books for example has become boring
because I read like the top 300 books
about business when I was in high school
um it becomes repetitive
um so you go you go deeper you go
literally read primary sources which is
what I do a lot now
um and you know that becomes fascinating
and so
definitely start by reading like reading
is the number one way in which I learn I
just do it with my ears and to start
with 10 books a year and understand them
well but if you unlock the superpower of
listening
and like you and me you finished I
finished two audiobooks a week I've done
that for about 16 years
um okay you can listen to the same book
over and over again or you can diversify
the the sources so that's one thing you
can do yeah one of the things that I
found the speed listening really helps
with is uh just reducing the cost of a
book
so I was at this philanthropy retreat
thing over the weekend where people were
talking about Ai and biosecurity and
pandemic prevention and like how do we
avert nuclear war and I just found
myself being like I have no idea what
anyone is talking about here and so in
conversations with people I was like
what's like the one or two books you'd
recommend to kind of get up to speed on
what the what what the hell's going on
with nuclear for example and this Chapel
I spoke to who works in policy was like
you know there's this really good book
called The Bomb which came out recently
that charts the history of nuclear war
from the 1960s onwards
you should try that out and I was like
all right cool and immediately just
opened up Amazon on my phone bought it
on Audible I saw it was a 12 hour read I
was like cool I can get through this in
about three hours yeah something like
that and I started listening to it on
the drive home and already like you know
two hours two or so hours into it like
listening about about 2.5 x speed
because there was a lot of names and
stuff and I'm not overly familiar with
how the US government works so it's like
yeah let's slow down a bit I know I feel
like oh my God like I now have so much
context on the nuclear thing which I I
had zero on like other than studying the
Cuban Missile Crisis in like history in
when I was 15. beyond that I knew
nothing about any of this and it's like
oh it turns out there's all this like
drama between the Air Force and the Navy
and the Army and the Marines all the
stuff around nuclear like stuff with the
Kremlin the hotline there's some really
cool and if that if that had been
recommended to me as a book and I would
have seen how dense it is just like I'm
never gonna I wouldn't have read Brandon
Sanderson because I've seen how big the
freaking way of Kings is but as an
audiobook as an audio Booker like a
speed multiple
it only costs me about three hours of
time where I'm driving or at the gym to
be able to actually ingest a lot of
information about nuclear and maybe I
can't recite the names of like oh in
1963 this was the person who was the
head of the Department of State or
whatever but I don't really need to
because what I care about is getting the
gist and a general understanding of the
topic yep the story and the plot plus
it's asynchronous time right to read a
book you need to not drive not work out
not cook you're sitting at a desk you
know even reading while you're on the
trainer and an Uber is difficult but if
I'm listening you know I finish my zoom
call like here's my how my day goes
right I wake up in the morning airpods
go in I start listening I brush my teeth
I'm listening I'm cooking breakfast I'm
listening I take them out when I'm
eating breakfast with my teammates and
then if I have five minutes between a
zoom call and where I'm in I'll listen
and then I finished the zoom call I'm
gonna head over here cool I start
listening I get in the Uber I like might
pick up a phone call or two the second
the phone call ends I go back to
listening my airpods just don't leave my
ears and then I only stop listening I
texted you hey I'm downstairs but I can
do things and listen at the same time
and when you show up downstairs I stop
listening and so all that dead time in
the day typically it's like three to
four hours I'm listening to a book but
I'm listening at 3x speed
all right we're just going to take a
quick break from the podcast to
introduce our sponsor which is very
excitingly heal I have been a paying
customer of huel since 2017 so it's been
about six years now that I've been using
Hugh fairly regularly I started eating
Hill in my fifth year of medical school
and I've been using heal regularly ever
since because you know I like to be
productive I you know my calendar is
full with a lot of things and often I
don't have the time or don't make the
time to have a particularly healthy
breakfast or a particularly healthy
lunch my favorite flavor is salted
caramel because 400 calories you get 40
grams of protein which is absolutely
insane and you also get a decent healthy
mix of carbohydrates and fiber and fat
along with 26 different vitamins and
minerals which are all very good for the
body there's nine different flavors of
this to choose from my favorite is a the
banana version and also the Salted
Caramel version so what I do is I take
my two scoops I put them into my
NutriBullet blender type thing although
you can just use a normal Shaker if you
want I mix it up normally with water but
a little bit of milk to add a bit more
of a milkshake like consistency to it
and then I just sip that while I'm on my
desk doing my work in the morning and it
ensures that I get a very healthy
breakfast in that's nutritionally
complete rather than some high sugar
cereal which is what I would have
defaulted to instead also heal is
ridiculously reasonably priced like a
meal 400 calories comes out to one pound
68 per meal which is super super cheap
compared to what the alternative would
be if you were ordering takeout for
example anyway if you like the idea of
getting these cheap and healthy and
nutritionally complete meals in your
diet then head over to heal.com forward
slash Deep dive and if you use that URL
heal.com forward slash Deep dive they
will send you a free t-shirt which are
quite nice and also a free kind of
shaker bottle type thing with your first
order so thank you so much Hill for
sponsoring this episode this episode is
very kindly brought to you by
trading212. now people ask me all the
time for advice about investing because
I've made a bunch of videos about it on
the YouTube channel and my advice for
most people is generally invest in Broad
stock market index funds which is
exactly what you can do completely for
free with trading 212. it's a great app
that lets you trade stocks and funds and
ETFs and foreign exchange if you really
want to and one of the great things
about the app is that if you're new to
the world of investing you can actually
invest with fake money you don't have to
put real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what they the
market is doing in real time so you can
see had I invested 100 pounds into this
thing what would my return have been X
weeks or X months further down the line
once you've got some comfort with that
then it's super easy to deposit money
into your trading tube into account you
can use Apple pay like I do initially or
you can use a direct bank transfer and
then once the money is in your trading
212 account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want the other
really cool feature about trading 212 is
their pies feature so what you can do is
you can follow people who've created
investing pies for example someone might
have a pie where I don't know 30 of his
apple and 20 is Tesla and 10 is the S P
500 and you can follow people on the app
and see what pies they've created and
you can see the performance of those
pies and then you can just copy and
paste a particular pie into your own
account and so that means like let's say
you've got 100 pounds to invest and
you've put 50 of it into the S P 500 but
you want to be a little bit more
experimental with the other 50 pounds
you could invest it into a pie where
someone else is generally a pro or
someone in their bedroom who just loves
the markets has already done all the
homework for you the app also lets you
Auto invest which is a great thing
because then you can automatically
invest a percentage of your paycheck
into the thing every month and so if you
haven't yet started with investing and
you want to give it a go then you can
download the app on the App Store and if
you use the coupon code Ali Ali at the
checkout that will give you a totally
free share worth up to 100 pounds it's
available on iPhone and Android and you
can check it out by typing in trading212
into your respective App Store so thank
you so much trading212 for sponsoring
this episode that thing that you just
said I imagine there are some people
listening to this thinking oh my
God that sounds incredible and just as
many probably thinking oh my God
that sounds like the worst thing in the
world this guy's a psychopath like
um I wonder like I mean most people do
the same thing but with music
right so let's take Hamilton for example
um I eat biographies for breakfast I'm
obsessed right like I literally wrote a
rap album about the life of Arnold
Schwarzenegger after I listened to
Hamilton for the first time
um Hamilton the musical it's about two
hours 40 minutes long it is the best
biography of Hamilton in my opinion
right it's dramaticized but like you
can't take away from the beat and lyrics
and everything else when you listen to
music it's exactly like listening to a
book especially if you pay attention to
the lyrics by the way one really cool
thing is if you start listening to a lot
of audiobooks you will notice and
remember all the lyrics from all the
songs you listen to most people who I am
friends with
um you know they listen to the beat or
the melody and they don't necessarily
recall or understand the lyrics they
need to look at the lyrics on their
phone to really and take them for me
like both happen because I've trained
that part of my brain
but if you already do this for music why
do you do it with music because it
enriches your life It Makes You Happy
Well Brandon sanderson's uh you know the
way of Kings enriches my life I'm sorry
even more than music and so again it
doesn't matter if it's fantasy or
fiction or philosophy or sci-fi I listen
because it makes me happy it's it's
beautiful it's enjoyable I'm living
inside this world and the joy that you
get from a book if you've read a book is
so much deeper than the Joe you get from
watching a movie or watching a TV series
and so I don't watch TV I don't watch
movies I just consume books but I do it
with my ears
do you like uh presumably on on the few
occasions where you do watch TV movies
YouTube videos do you speed those up as
well or do you sort of slow it down and
watch it as the Director pre intended or
some like that I cannot deal with
the speed of movies and TV shows at this
point so I use an app on my on my
computer called uh
video speed controller uh you can
increment the speed by 0.1 increments
and when like my friends don't notice I
I up it by 20 but if I was watching by
myself I'd want to do my 5x speed
YouTube on my computer automatically
plays a 3X speed for everything
um and again okay we talked about you
know working out right before this when
I was younger
you know lifting 145 pounds was
difficult now
I can then press that however long you
want me to
um and so you build the muscle right if
you build the muscle and you can bench
press like 225 easy
um there's no reason to set the
resistance to 145. set it to 225. and so
the trick is just practice listening
faster and here's the key
some of us are able to read at a
thousand words per minute like there are
people who can do that right a college
professor in the United States typically
will read about a 330 350 words per
minute no one goes how dare you read
that quickly
it's the same thing it's just that the
upper level that is accessible to most
people and listening is a lot easier to
reach and here's why
we've been listening for hundreds of
thousands of years
we've only been reading
for like a thousand years
we evolved to be really good at
storytelling and paying attention and
processing with our ears
it's a hack you know the idea of writing
characters and then decoding them it's
an amazing hack but it's a hack
um it's not what humans evolved to learn
how to do
if you learn and here's the thing right
reading is a highly computational
behavior for the brain to do typically
about 97 of your brain function is
actually working on decoding and only
three percent can focus on comprehension
but if you listen like three percent is
focusing on decoding 97 focus on
comprehension so computers
are designed for computing the really
good at Computing and so if you could
Outsource the computational work
of reading to a computer that's the best
except AI was not good enough to read
like a human until
just about now
um and so now you can do that just think
about it this way right how many of us
do long division math in our head nobody
you pull up your iPhone you do it on
your phone
it makes sense to do the same thing with
reading
um do you listen to podcasts very much
I didn't used to and the quality of
podcasts significantly increased over
the last 10 months so now I do my
favorite is how to take over the world
by Ben Wilson hmm what's up I haven't
come across that oh my God it's amazing
okay so I came up I came across this
podcast
the first episode I listened to was uh
the life of Julius Caesar uh and then I
listened to Napoleon's biography by him
and then he recently put out the
biography of
um Brigham Young
and uh what he'll do is he'll read like
five primary sources and he'll produce
like a two to three hour uh biography
podcast he's got a great voice and then
he'll also find the overarching concepts
from all their lives for example they
all eat fast they all attack fast
they're all really good at communication
and it's fascinating and so you know I
love the idea of taking over the world
not the same violent way that people
used to but there's a lot that you can
learn so I'm obsessed with Hamilton I'm
also obsessed with Napoleon
um and you know Sandy for Julius Caesar
and so the more you study people the
more interesting it is and so that the
reason why I didn't like podcasts
historically is you know you got one
person interviewing another person
another person editing basically three
human hours running to one minute of you
consuming but if I fly from like
California to New York and I listen to
the
book Obama row before he became
president that book is eight hours long
I listen to 2x speed 3x speed by the
time I land I finished that book it's
like I sat next to Obama the entire time
but he spent an hour thinking about
every single minute of what he was going
to say
and so books used to be a more dense
source of information uh podcasts
recently have improved dramatically the
other thing that happened to me is that
now read enough books that it's actually
difficult for me to find new things in
books but the lead time from something
being discovered
to appearing in a podcast is faster than
the lead time for something being
discovered to be published in a book and
so when I was in college uh I knew I was
in the right classes when I started not
being able to Wikipedia the concepts
about photovolithics engineering that we
were learning in class and I could only
learn that from the professors directly
and so what I did is I took all these
classes and I would email professors at
Stanford and MIT and Harvard to like ask
them additional questions
um it's now become the case that for
most topics you can learn more Cutting
Edge stuff from podcasts so that's
really cool hmm
yeah that's interesting that's a good
way of thinking about it um the way I
think about audiobooks versus podcasts
is
audiobooks are really good if I want to
get like a just a broad General like
sort of Blitz about about a particular
topic but one thing I like about
podcasts is that usually like for
example if Tim if Tim Ferriss is an
interviewing Morgan house all about the
psychology of money like the book is
good but in a way him asking questions
to the thing will spark other things in
my mind of like even though I've read
the book I still find the interview
valuable or I can't one when Cal Newport
is interviewing Tim first about
something I'm very familiar with both of
their work and so the way they talk
about it has a meta level of awareness
to the topic but there's no point me
listening to a podcast about nuclear
because I know nothing about the topic
and so to get the foundational
groundwork the books are sick because
then at that point I can understand what
the experts are talking about
and then the other thing I would say is
amazing about books is if you listen to
fantasy or sci-fi World building it's
really difficult to build a world and
have it be
um
congruent and consistent and actually
there's a lot of strategy in doing that
and so you get a lot of emotional
rewards uh by listening to a fantasy or
sci-fi audiobook that someone has spent
a lot of time thinking about
um do you have any kind of note-taking
process when it comes to learning from
audiobooks and podcasts and stuff I
don't
um I remember it all in my head
um but the way I think about it is
everybody has a mental model of the
universe in their brain yep
it's like a Google map where some areas
you zoom in it's more pixelated other
places like it's really fleshed out and
all the topics are connected to each
other and uh you know when people get
down YouTube wormholes and start
believing conspiracy theories
um you know if the mental model is that
gigantic Street
that conspiracy theory is a shrub that
lives over here that's not connected to
your main Tree in any shape way or form
uh a good example of this is I used to
believe the Vikings were mythical
creatures I didn't think they ever
existed I thought they were like dwarves
and elves and then I went and visited
Denmark and I was in Copenhagen
um and this girl said this thing about
Vikings and I was taken aback because
she talked about them like they existed
in history and then I realized they did
like King Bluetooth was a real person
um who had a chipped tooth that turned
blue
um and he United like Denmark and
Switzerland and Sweden and all these
other countries
and they lived like right before World
War one and I was like whoa and that was
the first time that Vikings were
introduced into my mental model of the
universe so it all started to get
connected and so I consume a lot of
books I consume a lot of podcasts I talk
to a lot of people I think a lot and so
my brain keeps making these
fiber connections between things
for note-taking I take notes on all my
zoom calls on Apple notes I love Apple
notes um I use them religiously and have
done so since like 2011.
um
one of the things we've now built in
speechify is when you listen to an
audiobook or PDF or whatever you get
both the text highlighted for you in
your library and you can listen and it
works both in iOS and on web and you can
click on a sentence and it'll allow you
to take the note in there and one thing
I want to do is ingest all the podcasts
and if you want to make a comment on
something that you said uh you can and
then the audience can upvote and it
turns into a subreddit essentially like
you can build a community for the
podcast listeners
and then it makes all podcasts uh
indexable and searchable by topic so you
can search neurotropics and you can see
every time the Joe Rogan or Tim Ferriss
or Kyle Newport are you talked about you
know whatever neurotropic of choice
um and so that's something to me that's
really exciting so I'm we're trying to
build that into speechify
yeah the the thing around building a
model of the world in your head versus
outside of your head
um you know this you might be familiar
with familiar with Tiago Forte building
a second brain all that kind of stuff
yeah uh all of these new note-taking
apps that are allegedly trying to
Outsource the work of the brain to an
app because a computer can understand an
AI or whatever can link create links
that you might not have found useful
yourself
um and so I've been sort of dabbling in
the space for the last like three years
now but I've never I've never once had a
situation where my computer has created
a link that I wouldn't have created in
my head one thing it is useful for is
for example let's say I had a call with
someone two years ago interviewing them
about the book and I tagged it with a
thing and two years later when I'm
refining that chapter I search for the
thing and it's like oh okay and I now
have a searchable transcript which is
useful but beyond that I'm not sure what
actual utility I've gotten from the let
a device connect your thoughts to things
the CRM that I have in my computer is
amazing for people so I put a note in
instead of anyone's contact in my phone
that when I put them in so let's say I
meet someone at a party I'll be like all
right Connor yellow hat Gangnam Style
because we danced Gangnam Style at the
time and then I'll search that every
time I need that person I'll text in the
question so a lot of my knowledge is
actually linked to the people that I
know right you get a bunch of like
random texts from me I'd say anything
for most people know me because I think
about random things at four in the
morning uh or when I you know get out of
the shower and I always build them up at
this point I've actually shifted to
using iMessage and email for most of my
communications because it just makes it
easier to follow
um and then everything is in Google now
as an Apple notes and so I I know how I
write and so I search for the right
keywords to unlock that thing the other
thing is I have an app on my phone that
organizes my contacts by the date in
which I entered them so if I met someone
at the Christmas party 2018. that's good
I will go to that date and then I look
at who came into my contacts booth and
oh yeah it was Jimmy and then I'll send
him a message
um so that's the thing that I really
rely on and if I didn't have it I would
cry and so I backed that up a lot um do
you use the CRM for like just work stuff
or also personal stuff oh yeah personal
stuff even more than work exactly what's
it called oh I don't know like my CRM is
just the contacts book in my phone and
Apple notes like it's not but you just
add like some level of metadata to the
thing that helps jog your memory and
stuff nice
um okay let's go away from this sort of
deep sort of speed listening E-Type
rabbit hole for a bit so you're you're
in college you're taking a lot of these
classes you're consuming a lot of
information and you're using this hack
together text-to-speechy thing that you
and Tyler kind of created to make it
easier for you to absorb information
because you've got dyslexia and reading
is like a real nightmare exactly
um what happens next in the cliff
Weisman story and I guess also you're a
very like sociable dude
um and I remember last time we spoke you
mentioned that you did some like Rogue
things socially when you were in in
college I wonder if you can elaborate on
that yeah of course
um cool so I don't drink I don't smoke
I've never been high I've never been
drunk
um there's no way you're getting me to
touch a cigarette
um not psychedelics either yeah
um the way I think about psychedel I
have a lot of friends who love
psychedelics many many close friends
um
psychedelics the way they are described
to me is you know
let's say this is the lens for the world
you get to look at the world from
another angle you shift it it's like
clicking a reset button the thing is I
love how my brain functions like I'm so
happy
I do not want to roll the dice and
resetting it and I've also had a lot of
friends who have had like a
life-changing experience with
psychedelics that were that were
negative right right oh yeah many many
okay
um
and I don't want to risk it I'd rather
stay stay as I am maybe when I'm like
you know 60 and and life becomes boring
and I want to change something but so
far I I'm very happy uh I'm the happiest
person I've ever met really I I don't I
don't want to shift it
um okay so I'm 18 year old Cliff
um you know I'm just about to graduate
high school at this point in my life I
became obsessed with parkour
um so when I was six I saw a movie where
Jackie Chan did a backflip and I was
like obviously I'm gonna learn how to do
this and I I got into University and so
you know I could do less work in school
and I would just spend like six hours a
day doing parkour
I was like working on like double
backflips and I started doing hackathons
got to Brown
oh my God and brown was ranked for eight
years in a row the happiest School in
the world
um people were interesting and
interested and for the first time
everybody was like someone I could learn
something new from it was a huge shift
and even though you know I went through
like a public high school in California
that this was a very different
environment
and so what I did is I would uh I would
go to the dining hall and I very quickly
realized the best thing about college is
the people who were there much more
important than the classes and I would
have two dinners every single night I
would grab a plate I would go to a table
exactly like this so you have eight
people sitting at the table I'd look for
one that has six or seven people it'd be
like hey can I turn you guys what's your
name Ali I'm Cliff nice to meet you can
I grab a seat sure
how's it going and then I talked to
everybody in that table I'd finished my
food at this point I was trying to eat
3000 calories a day I get two more
plates and I go and I'd sit at another
table and then I'd grab a cup of tea and
I said another table actually sorry I
had like three dinners a night
and I would do this for the first two
months of every single semester first
semester second semester and I did this
every year so I got to know
60 of my freshman class uh within the
first two months and then I got another
class underneath and class underneath
and I got to know a lot of the seniors
and the Juniors and even when I
graduated I would fly back and I was
crashing on Valentine's couch and I
would do this again and
um I would host workshops for adoc which
is the admitted students day and you
know I'd get people to open up and so
I'd meet all those people even if they
didn't come to Brown
um before I got to Brown I knew that I
did not want to drink and I was like
cool I gotta make sure that I don't have
any social inhibitions even without
drinking and you know I think right
before that I'd read the four hour week
for the first time and how to win
friends and so I combined the Comfort
challenges that Tim Ferriss suggests
with the chapter about smiling uh from
Dale Carnegie's book and so every time
I'd walk down the street and someone big
was walking across I'd lock eyes with
them and I'd flash a smile in their
Direction and my goal was to get to
smile back and the great thing about
that is number one you become very happy
from this physiologically because if you
smile you know your brain becomes and
then the other person is smiling at you
genuinely and I always play this game to
this day especially in airports but I
would go with like a coffee shop and I'd
try to negotiate a 15 discount I'd lie
on the floor on a Starbucks for like 15
seconds 20 seconds to give myself a time
out I'd go to the mall and ask out you
know every person who walked by just to
build the muscle and
I got good at just not being shy and so
I'm the first person dancing on a table
at any party I just don't drink
um and that was really really useful and
anyone can do it it's just a matter of
practicing and then that's served me
really well because throughout College I
did 42 hackathons I think
um and I met a lot of friends in all
those events and like
I'd be the first person to ask questions
every time you know someone interesting
came to to school and you know I'd build
a relationship with them
um I'd enter like there's a rap battle
cool I'll do the rap battle there's a
break dance battle cool I'll do the
breakdance battle someone's playing
basketball or a sport I like let's say a
sport I've never played before I'm
always in
um I just have no inhibitions about
going to do stuff and I love putting
myself outside my comfort zone always
um and that served me really well and
then when I graduated and I started
working on speechai full time it was
quite lonely because I couldn't meet new
people and one of the best things about
Brown is you have artists and musicians
and philosophers and actors and people
who are into math and physics and
computer science and history it's
incredible cross-pollination of all
these things but downtown San Francisco
is just All Tech Bros so that was a lot
less interesting and I was living with
my brother
and all the people who I was working
with like I had I had hired them and so
there weren't that many people so I
started flying back to Brown every month
or two
and then I realized that there were a
bunch of cool people on Instagram and
YouTube and Twitter so I just started
dming people and even before that I was
really good at Cold messaging people on
email Founders especially and one of the
strategies I developed once they got to
the point where I'd read all the books
that I could read to learn about a topic
is I'd make a Google sheet of the 100
people who knew about the topic the most
and then I'd message every single one of
them on Instagram Facebook LinkedIn
email and then I'd follow up it's like
on a zoom call once I got a zoom call
I'd be like whoa this is amazing you
know so much about Performance Marketing
you live in Israel Denmark Chicago cool
uh can I come
say hello in person like I I I it's easy
for me to come visit Denmark on like
Sunday
um can I come by I'm like yeah sure and
then fly there and then I'd meet them
and so you know it doesn't matter if
it's an athlete or a musician or like an
author like recently I went and I spent
some time with Brandon Sanderson in in
Utah and I you know
one of my favorite rappers lives in Las
Vegas so I'll fly to his studio and I'll
record with him
um or there's like this
um like media Mogul who is like an
incredible
um agent for actors so I'm going to meet
him in Aspen in like three days and
after that I'm gonna go to Las Vegas and
after that I'm gonna go
um need like Orlando Bloom in LA because
he's a big user his future fight like if
there is someone who I think is awesome
I will just build a relationship with
them and then the way I got really good
at Performance Marketing is I just made
a list of the top 100 best performing
consumer subscription companies in the
world and I went and I sat behind the
founders of grammarly of audible of goop
without a shave club
um of of you know
Robin Hood Etc and I saw how they bought
ads and then I met you know
Amara and Thomas and Matt from yes
Theory or Logan or Jimmy and I just
would study how they created content and
then I gotta go to creating content and
then I wanted to know how to hire
Engineers so I found that ctOS of all
the top startups John Collison whatever
and I'd talk to them about it and then
I'd understand how they did it and I'd
figure out the process and then I'd
implement the process and so really my
strategy as CEO speeches wise if you're
a Founder your number one rule is to
learn you learn how to code how to
design how to talk to users
um your number your top three goals as a
CEO is make sure there's enough money in
the bank set the vision and make sure
the right people are in the right seats
and so a company by definition the word
means a collection of people so your
role is to collect incredible people and
then have them grow in the same
direction for a really big vision
and so you know I used to be the head of
engineering it's fine I used to be the
header product of speechify I used to be
the CMO at speechify not CM I led
marketing and Performance Marketing and
you know brand whatever it might be so
I'll read every single book there is
about the topic like literally 100 books
until I'm a subject matter expert and
then I'll find all of the number one
practitioners in the field and I will
make friends with them and I will study
how they do it and then you know maybe I
can teach them something and they can
teach me something else and then I'll do
a ton of experiments and I'll rewrite
the Playbook of how to do this thing and
then I'll find someone who's more
talented at that operation than me and
I'll have them leave the department and
I'll go and run the next Department
after that
um and so you know that one of my
favorite things in life is to just make
friends with the most awesome people in
the world right so I love this podcast
you know how to take over the world
because it tells you the stories of just
the most badass people in history well
there's a lot of badass people alive
today I would argue more badass than any
other people who have ever lived because
they've had the benefit of listening to
all these books listening to all these
podcasts bro every 13 year old already
gets to read everything that Newton
never wrote about geometry and then by
the time they graduate high school they
know all the calculus man Newton didn't
have anything through oh he has the line
if I have seen further is because of I
stood on the shoulders of giants so we
had you know capernus kiss and Galileo
but like everybody today is so much more
awesome than people who lived in the
past because they get to benefit from
everything that everyone else has ever
written or said
plus you have an iPhone an external
brain and you can bench press like you
can make yourself amazing and so there's
all these incredible people I want to be
friends with all of them and so that's
what I do
why do you want to be friends with all
of them like what's what's driving that
so number one I have this huge urge to
be the best person that I can be
um so if I look at like my top three
goals in life number one is to make
myself the best person I can be and have
kids who are greater than me number two
is love I think love is the most
important thing in life and the more you
give it the more you have to give it's
like fire you light a flame and you can
then light another one without
extinguishing the original one you know
Renewable Energy Engineering energy
cannot be created or destroyed but love
can
um it's like a jug where as you pour of
it
um The Jug gets bigger has more water in
so I think Love Is Magic so maximize
love in my life whether it be with my
friends
um with my users with my kids with my
partner whatever it might be uh and
number three is to create as much value
in the world as possible and Elevate the
collective quality of life and I see
creating value as a function of love
it's how you love on someone who you've
never met before
um you know for speechify 15 of the
reviews on the App Store are people who
say they cried when they started using
the app because of some impactful in
their lives
um I'll tell you you know a short story
which is right before I graduated
college
I wrote this 30 page book sorry 30 page
paper about my World Views
and I finished writing it at like four
in the morning and I was writing the
last paragraph of this thing and I had
taken all My Views and I distilled them
down into the 28 principles that I
believe that most other people don't
believe and you can find this on medium
and the last paragraph Was
in one of those days where Cliff was
asleep in the book when he was 10 year
olds 10 years old imagine if he had a
dream that he could right
if you could read books about how to not
get bullied about how to be a good
athlete about how to learn about math
about how to figure out how to take a
challenge and not being able to go to
computer science and figure it out you
know how to deal with a psychological
challenge of having your younger
siblings who are smarter than him
um on how to make friends
imagine if you told them that you know
he would actually go to college I don't
think he'd believe you or that he'd go
to go to Brown
imagine if you told him that who he is
today is greatly shaped by the fact that
he is dyslexic and that he learned how
to overcome that challenge when he was 9
10 years old
um
and so I cried when I wrote this
paragraph and I sent it to my girlfriend
at the time it's like a big paper but I
had like four spelling mistakes three
spelling mistakes and it's because I can
hear the spelling mistakes of
speechifying I couldn't believe it and
so I submitted this paper and
immediately went on to write thank you
notes so my eighth grade teacher Mr
Bloom who let me come in 15 minutes
early and Summarize the book to my
sophomore year teachers assistant Mark
reisler who would sit behind me and say
that one but I didn't know which one of
the options from the squiggly Red Lion
to pick because two two and two sounded
exactly the same to me
and to some of my professors to my
parents and then I added one more guy
and I basically sent in this email and
it was like Hey You Don't Know Me I
don't know you but I just graduated
college
and number any thank you notes in the
list would not be complete without you
in fact I would not be the person I have
today without you and it was the dog
cats who is the founder of audible
and I sent that email it was a long
email like eight paragraphs and he
responded like 40 minutes later with a
longer email than the one I sent and he
went you know messages like this
um don't make my days and weeks but my
months
and we built a relationship
um
and to be like talking to doncast is
more exciting than talking to LeBron
um
the crazy thing is I get
about 25 emails like this a day at this
point or Instagram messages or you know
Facebook messages Etc uh people who use
speechifying the same way because
audible's got like 450 000 titles
speechified let's listen to the entire
internet
um
and so the cool thing is like
as I developed these relationships
I get inspired by the people who I meet
because not everyone's story is on the
internet you know
um there's a lot of people who will
build a cool product I'll think it's
awesome and typically if someone builds
a cool product you probably think the
product is cool you'll probably think
the person is cool too so I just said a
ton of cold messages all day if I see
something cool I I message the person I
say hey you build something cool you
know would love to be your friend I'll
ask a couple of questions whatever it
might be
and that's how I approach recruiting and
that's why the team is speechified so
strong too is like we just hire awesome
people who led teams and built awesome
great things
um and so the goal is to just surround
give as much love as I can to the rest
of the world
um be able to give as much love as I can
um and just learn and you know when you
exhaust books people are the next
Frontier
right we're going to take a very quick
break from the podcast to introduce our
sponsor which is brilliant.org brilliant
has been a supporter of my channel for
the last several years I've been using
that product for the last several years
and it's the best app I've ever found
for online courses in maths and science
and computer science the courses are
really fun and interactive and engaging
and you learn stuff and then you apply
it with a practical puzzle and you learn
a bit more and then you've applied a bit
more so it's generally a way more
engaging and interesting way of learning
stuff compared to how we might have been
taught in school for example my favorite
courses on brilliant are the computer
science courses so back when I was
applying to med school I was actually
torn between medicine and computer
science and I went for medicine in the
end which I don't regret but there was
always a part of me that really wanted
to understand how computer science works
and so when I started taking the
computer science courses on brilliant it
really helped me understand like at a
deep level what the deal is with the
basics of computer science like they've
got a fantastic course introduction to
algorithms they've got a whole course on
cryptocurrencies which is all about how
cryptocurrencies actually work and how
the kind of sha-256 encryption works and
it teaches the topic of cryptography and
Security in a really fun and engaging
way which is way better than any other
explanation I found on the internet
anyway if any of that stand up you're
straight and you would like to level up
your knowledge and your thinking in
terms of maths or science or computer
science then do head over to
brilliant.org forward slash Deep dive
and the first 200 people to use that
link which is also in the video
description and in the show notes we'll
get 20 off the annual premium
subscription so thank you so much
brilliant for sponsoring this episode
and let's get right back to the podcast
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by wework now this is particularly
exciting for me because I have been a
full paying customer of wework for the
last two years now I discovered it
during you know when the pandemic was in
the on the verge of being lifted and I
spent like the whole year just sort of
sitting in my room making YouTube videos
but then I discovered wework and I was a
member of me and Angus my team members
we were members of the wework in
Cambridge and they have like hundreds of
other locations worldwide as well and it
was incredible because we had this
fantastic beautifully designed office
space to go to to work and we found
ourselves like every day just at nine
o'clock in the morning just going to
wework because it was a way nicer
experience working from the co-working
space than it was just sitting at home
working these days what me and everyone
on my team has is the all-access pass
which means you're not tied to a
specific wework location but it means
you can use any if there's several
hundred co-working spaces around London
around the UK and also around the world
and one of the things I really love
about the co-working setup is that it's
fantastic as a bit of a change of
scenery so these days I work from home
I've got the studio at home but if I
need to get some focused writing work
done and I've been I'm feeling a bit
drained just sitting at my desk all day
I'll just pop over to the local wework
which is about a 10 minute walk from
where I am I'll take my laptop with me
I'll get some free coffee from there
I'll get a few snacks and it's just such
a great Vibe and you get to meet cool
people I've made a few friends through
meeting them at wework and it's just
really nice being an environment almost
like a library but kind of nicer because
there's like a little bit of soft music
in the background and there's other kind
of startup Bros and creators and stuff
in in there as well and it's just my
absolute favorite co-working space of
all time it's super easy to book a desk
or book a conference room using the app
and it's a great place to meet up with
team members if you're going to
collaborate and you'll live in different
places they've got unlimited tea and
coffee and herbal teas and drinks on tap
and they've also got various kind of
after work events that happen like happy
hours and yoga and a few other exercise
type things and you can also take in
guests so often when guests will come
over to visit I'll say hey let's pop
into wework and we'll just work from
there for the whole day and then we'll
go out for dinner sometime in the
evening anyway if you're looking for a
co-working space for you or your team
then I'd 100 recommend wework like I
said I've been a pain customer for
theirs for the last two years which is
why it's particularly exciting that
they're now sponsoring this episode and
if you want to get 50 off your first
booking then do head over to we.com
forward slash Ali and you can use the
coupon code Ali at checkout Ali to get
50 off your first booking so thank you
so much wework for sponsoring this
episode so let's say someone's listening
to this and they're like and I'm I'm I I
feel like I'm sort of in this in this
boat where
you know I saw you very kindly shared
your like goals spreadsheet with me on
Google Sheets the other day and I was I
was looking at it and I was just like oh
wow you're so intentional about like
people that you want to meet and like
want to hang out with and and part of me
was thinking
I'd like to do that as well like that
seems cool and you know for example
when I had Brandon Sanderson on the
podcast like that that was sick like
that was awesome
um and I it was a cold a cold message on
Twitter and I almost didn't believe that
it turned out it turned out the way it
did
but another part of me was a sort of
scared I think there was a fear around
like oh
sending call messages seems like just
like hey it seems like a lot of work be
it like it's kind of weird like I feel
like I already struggle hard enough to
keep to keep in touch with my actual
friends let alone trying to then expand
this network for people around the world
and even a part of me was like uh Cliff
must have some kind of like insecurity
to be wanting to become friends with
with celebrities and I was like that's
weird like why am I why is that like
where my brain went with this because I
think it was it was me being afraid of
like that's really cool and I want to do
that but I'm but my ego is trying to
find reasons for to be like
oh you know you know I'm I'm more secure
on myself therefore I don't need to be
friends with
a famous person
and I think this is I feel like this is
similar to the attitude some people have
when if you see someone who's like very
successful at a thing and you kind of
feel like you want it like I want to be
successful with that thing
but you feel like there is something
stopping you from getting that like you
feel like you can't put in the time or
the effort or like me or it just
wouldn't be possible it's very easy to
be like oh I don't I don't actually want
the thing because oh you know that that
person's materialistic that's why they
have a Lamborghini I don't actually want
Lamborghini oh whatever that might look
like
um yeah so the funny part is like we're
talking about like being friends with
famous people but we're talking about
Brandon Sanderson like that's the thing
that both you and I are most excited
about Brandon Sanderson most of the
people who are watching this don't know
who he is and if they do know who he is
they have no idea what he looks like
yeah but man I again the guy who I
teared up messaging was the founder of
audible none of you guys knew who
doncast was before I don't care how
famous someone is yeah I care about what
they've done I care about their story I
care about how they've impacted the
world and how I can be inspired by them
and so the people with message like
they're a parkour athlete with like 1
000 followers on Instagram who are just
their core friends but they can do a
move that I can can't do they can do a
Webster they can do a beautiful Webster
and so I'm gonna message them and be
like hey Adam you have the best website
anybody I ever seen I know you live in
North Carolina would it be cool if I
hired you to coach me and I'll set up my
phone on FaceTime and I'll put my
airpods in and I'll just train for two
hours and pay you for that he's like
yeah for sure but you don't need to pay
me like I'm happy to coach you
and so like I'll just reach out to
people who I think are cool I don't care
if they're famous it just happens to be
there if they're famous I'm more likely
to know their story
um you know I'm a bigger fan of chaitu
or Simon who work with me than I am of
any any of these people
um and
yeah it's just the fact that like the
more you learn about people the more you
realize that the world is stacked with
Incredible human beings who also just
have such great character and again if
someone doesn't have good character if
they're like a jerk I have zero interest
in being their friend no matter what the
story is
um
and and that's that's the key is like
you gotta just do it all from a place of
curiosity and love
um to answer your previous question of
like oh it might take a lot of work and
take energy it doesn't take any work it
doesn't take any energy right so let's
say you're on Instagram
typically I send audio messages and I'm
like
hey Jason
I heard you on this podcast
I thought it was awesome I specifically
liked what you said about the tree of
knowledge I have the specific questions
about backflips can I ask you sure
um this is the question by the way you
know I'm working on this I'm doing this
blah 40 second message right if it's a
cold email dude I said at least
40 of these this week
um hey Steve I just was going through
the GitHub repository for the Mozilla
text-to-speech uh open source project
and I saw this contribution that you did
and I thought it was amazing uh you know
this can be a Twitter message could be
an email whatever
um
I'm working on this company called
speechify here's the link or even before
speechify I'm a student at Brown
University I'm studying Renewable Energy
Engineering I'd love to be a friend uh
like I'd love to be your friend like
that line all the time yeah I love it
like I'd love to get to know you maybe
be friends
um are you free for a zoom call to get
to know you like 3 P.M or 4 P.M on
Thursday or Friday
um my best Cliff that's it you're
talking about three lines yeah why you
think they're awesome yeah why you have
some sort of credibility and it's enough
to be interested in the topic to be a
student
um and a time that you suggest 80 of
people say yes really yeah I just got a
message it don't make it long yeah so
the thing is like one thing about me is
like I actually like couldn't care less
about people's like status sure in life
yeah when I was a freshman at Brown Jack
Dorsey came to give a talk Jack Dorsey
is the founder of Twitter and square
um and I like snuck into the talk late
but he was a great speaker and so at the
end I walked up and I was like hey I
really love the way he merged technology
and Design
could I Shadow you for a day in San
Francisco
um I'd love to learn how to do what you
do and he's like ah maybe and it's like
sweet can I get your secretary's email
and he's like sure here here's her email
a message no response message again no
response happened to be that at another
conference
um in St Louis he was speaking and he
like got off stage too quick for me to
make the relationship but I searched the
crowd for someone who had a square
t-shirt and I found one
um uh this guy Greg this woman sake and
I started talking to them
got Greg's email
later that summer I got a one-on-one
lunch from Jack Dorsey I was 18 years
old
um and just because I maintained the
relationship and you know they you know
engaged with me because they wanted to
recruit me to the company eventually and
I sent them this video of me pitching
this product that was really good but
still
um like I don't care like in my opinion
you know
it's a great thing for Jack to be
friends with me because I will introduce
him to a bunch of other cool things in
his life
um and that's the frame that any of you
guys listening to this should have when
you interact with a new person
um you know none of it matters
um it just matters like do you come into
things with good intention and as long
as you give more than you receive which
is what you should try to do all the
time your life will be amazing and
here's the thing like I said it costs me
nothing to give you love
and you know when I'm with Brandon
Sanderson to ask him this question that
I know you're curious to to know about
or when I see your video or you know
download your product to say hey you can
approve this in the following way hey I
mentioned this person about this product
that you built that I think is great
um it doesn't cost me anything but it
might benefit you tremendously and so if
you give 70 points of value to a
thousand people and they give you back
30 points of value man your life is so
much richer because you didn't lose
anything for like the good energy that
you spent you know with everybody else
so I rule if in a short period of time I
can significantly increase it some
increase someone else's life do it
and so you're already a master at this
right like the reason why you have a
YouTube channel is one day you woke up
and you're like hey
I know how to study for the medical
boards really well let me make a video
to teach people and then you're like oh
you know I love iPads let me make a
thing about how to take notes on iPads
and you build a following because you
genuinely shared the things that you
were good at with the community for no
other reason than you wanted to help and
the same thing was true for me I used to
write a lot of productivity medium blog
posts and I used to post them as a
organic post on the Facebook feed for
the freshman classes that would come at
the brown and then that feed got so big
with resources that it became a medium
post because it just stopped you know
matching the character limit
and then I I wrote another one if I was
a entrepreneur and I was starting at
Brown here's all the resources that I
wish I knew and like here's an index of
all the people on campus so I think are
really cool they should reach out to
um and hey you know I'm gonna go to this
conference in MIT uh tomorrow morning I
didn't know how to get to MIT until I
was a sophomore
um so if you're a freshman meet me at
this gate at 6 30 a.m here's a link to
register and I'll show you how to get to
MIT that's where I'm at Valentine who
became my best friend
um who let to be you know meeting the
girl that I dated for the rest of
college and all these good things that
happened in my life was just because I
was doing things
for nothing less than a desire to help
other people figure out how to figure
out things that I'm doing and you know a
lot of people talk about product Market
fit when they're working on startups one
thing I think people should talk about
more is founder product fit and so my
goal is you know to be the person that I
needed most when I was young and what I
really needed was someone to read my
books to me and so I also made sure that
my mission in life the thing I worked on
spend the most my time on was something
that was congruent with who I am and the
type of help that I needed
and so that's you know my way of giving
love into the universe in general is you
know I'm building the thing that I
needed and I get to benefit those people
and benefit myself because I'm uniquely
capable of doing that because I
understand the problem better than
anybody else and so if you can align
your life in that way or you find a
thing that you're is it a problem that
you yourself have right studying for
medical school and you solved it for
yourself and you can broadcast how to
solve that problem yeah great
yeah this is connecting a lot of dots in
my own in my own mind as you as you say
this because I think
like in my in my first year of med
school like you know we I was part of
the Islamic society and um there were
medical students in the in the in the
Years above and they would all share
like essay plans and notes and stuff and
it became the sort of like Islamic
Society Medics Community sharing notes
so then I was like I mean that's cool
but like cool why don't I do that within
my own College of my own cohort of
Medics and then made a Google Drive
sharing notes there and being like hey
guys if we all write three essays and
they're different and we share them with
each other like the 30 essays we can all
memorize with the exam and and that and
then a couple years later
um when I got super into like
evidence-based study techniques I
thought hey why don't I give a talk
about this because this would be a cool
thing and we just made a little Facebook
event and it was meant to be just for
the Islamic society and we booked out
the prayer room for seven people but
then it got 20 000 Impressions on
Facebook it has a Facebook event and
like sort of 120 people showed up
because it was like this is a talk
on how to study for exams and that gave
me that sort of thing
four years later one or three years
later when I started the YouTube channel
of that talk I gave three years ago went
down pretty well I still have the slides
from that I'm gonna make a video at some
point doing evidence-based study tips
but before I do that I need to make 100
videos so I can get good at making
videos and that that video that I made
181 videos later went viral and caused
the whole explosion of everything and as
you describe this thing of just sort of
like just putting yourself out there and
trying to be helpful and trying to just
add value in whatever way you can I
think a lot of people overthink this a
lot of people have this thing of oh I
couldn't possibly say anything publicly
Because unless it's perfect it can't go
out there and I was speaking to someone
over the weekend who's like been writing
in her journal for like a thousand words
a day for the last like eight years or
something and she wants to be a writer I
was like okay if you published anything
she was like no it's not good enough to
publish
and she was asking me how I became how I
was so sort of chill about this and it
was Austin cleon's book show your work
um which taught which gave me the model
of as long as the thing that you're
doing has the potential to benefit at
least one person then there's almost a
moral obligation on you to put it out
there and actually sent Austin a thank
you email like many years later
um with a piece at the bottom being like
I'd love to connect and then we ended up
connecting and he was on the Deep dive
and just really nice things happen just
sending a thank you email as a result of
that one book
um and that well yeah just the this idea
of putting putting Good Good Vibes out
there into the world just trying to be
helpful in whatever way you can and
trusting that like good things will
happen as a result three points of that
number one I have a rule if something
positive is said about anybody else in a
conversation with me I'll check and then
I'll text that person the positive thing
that was said about them because it cost
me nothing but you just made their day
yeah if I'm procrastinating and like I
want to like I don't know watch TV so I
won't watch TV I'll just send gratitude
notes to people that I love and it might
be that it's the first time I thought
about this person in six months but I'll
just send him a message by the way
that's how I maintain connection with
people who I'm close with even if I'm
not closer than the person
um the way I got into making YouTube
videos was when I was 15 I did parkour
and what we would do is we would shoot
ourselves on our little point-of-shoot
like cameras or iPod Touches that I
would make iMovie
show reels and I post that to YouTube
and you can find it has like I don't
know a thousand views per video
but then later I filed a patent when I
was in college for a 3D printed
skateboard break that I built and I had
to figure out how to printable I built
this 3D printed skateboard break you
mounted on the axle of skateboard break
you mounted on the axle of your
longboard yeah and then you twist your
heel and it'll stop your board for you
oh that's awesome yeah it was great and
so you know I built that in college and
so I patented it but it was a huge
hassle to patent like the online patent
system for the US is like designed by a
deranged DMV employee who like wanted to
like ruin the lives and productivity of
everybody who went through it yeah so I
learned how to do it and then I was like
okay well this literally took me three
days to figure out let me just make a
video walking people through how to do
this and so I did in that video got like
150 000 views and then I devised this
way of blocking the recommendations on
the right panel of YouTube so I wouldn't
get distracted and I would block the
main feed of YouTube as well and like
most people won't know how to select the
divs and use Adblock to do this let me
make a screenshot how to do this that
also got 150 000 views and then um
foreign
I got the scholarship for kids with
learning differences so basically I paid
for I paid for college
um and I did it by building all these
products when I was in college and I
hired 10 Freelancers to find and apply
to scholarships from me full-time and I
had like a bunch of criteria it'd be
like more than five thousand dollars
eligible as a non-us citizen who was
living in California who had like a you
know x amount GPA who studied energy or
had dyslexia or whatever
um and so one of the scholarships was
for the lion Fellowship they elect the
top 20 highest performing kids with
learning differences in the US and
Canada and I got into this thing and I
realized nobody was using Texas speech
and I was like are you guys kidding me
and so I got up on stage and I demoed
the tool that I built
um and you know three weeks later half
the people who were in that conference
had already sent me thank you notes
saying this completely changed my
education thank you and so when like the
15th person messaged me my mom had
called me up to dinner and I was like
give me 15 minutes and I screen recorded
how I used text-to-speech on my computer
I made a little YouTube video one take
and then I uploaded to YouTube the day
that things also got like 300 000 views
there's like thousands of comments
saying like I'm literally crying my you
know third graders doing homework by
herself this video got uploaded in like
2014 two years before I started working
on speech five the company
um and so don't try to get paid don't
try to like Arbitrage just put good
energy into the world and if you do that
um good things happen
right
I'd have to zoom in on the this like
thank you notes thing so you said that
you don't procrastinate you don't scroll
on social media okay but instead of
procrastinating typically if I'm low
energy in my work and I find it
difficult to focus I just pull on my
phone I go to iMessage and people who I
feel graded towards I send them specific
messages for what I feel gratitude about
wow that's such a positive way to waste
time on your phone exactly and don't
endless scroll Twitter like I imagine if
you're on like every time I'm on the
toilet multiple times a day you know my
default is Twitter I just scroll scroll
yeah I just go to iMessage and I message
people wow
oh man my life would be so much better
if that was my default like thumb action
rather than just another thing I do is I
use uh so my phone I activated the Child
Safety Lock so
um
what's it called on your phone uh when
it blocks you from being on an app after
15 minutes oh yeah that thing um yeah
yeah so that thing um
they just released an API for this
um
Apple Focus mode yeah
I set my phone as if I'm a five-year-old
and parental controls and I do not know
the code to open that parental control
thing and I haven't known the code for
about five years my brother knows it my
girlfriend knows it like all the rest of
my team know it uh but I don't and so I
get two minutes of Instagram a day
two minutes on Twitter
two minutes of YouTube
she went to tick tock and then they're
all locked and I can't open them uh if
there's something specific I need to do
I can ask someone to open them for me
and it'll be open open for a couple of
minutes but then they're immediately off
again
um yeah I don't even have the app I
think for YouTube on my phone
um and that's how I defend myself
wow all right I'm gonna I'm gonna try
this this this group this gratitude
message thing seems like a very easy
life hack for just like I'm just all
loads of good things happening because I
find that one of the issues I have is
I mean as I as I'm sure you do as well
like when you've got a lot going on it's
easy to let relationships slide it's
easy to be like oh I've got an extra two
hours this evening oh because uh meeting
finished audio because I was I'm
actually at home oh great two hours I
can work on my book I can do this thing
I can do something work related
and
I know that that's the wrong answer here
because like every single thing I've
ever read around you know how to design
your life and all this stuff so that's
really what I do yeah um first of all I
do the same thing as you if I have a
free time I'm spending on a speech of my
butt
you remember maybe a month before I got
to the UK you crossed my mind because I
thought that I was moving here and I
send you a message I was like Hey I want
to be in the UK at this time do you want
to hang out you're like yeah I was like
how about this date literally a month
and a half two months into the future
yeah and we booked a time to hang out
and you were like do you want to do a
podcast too and I was like yeah so we
put time on the calendar
oh Monday came I was looking forward to
hanging out with Elite so I book all of
it in advance yeah
um
there's like this really cool you know
Adventure vacation I'm organizing with a
couple of friends you know I got this
idea for a thing and then I messaged
everybody they all said yes and then you
know I had a teammate start to organize
it for us and so you know we
Consolidated a time but like that one is
not random it's like happening
organically but like it got initiated in
a month and a half beforehand and then I
have a couple of friends where we have
like we know we're gonna get together
every quarter and so when I think about
them I'll message them that nice thing
and I was like hey love you guys
thinking of you why don't we meeting up
for you know rhinos this quarter how
about we go to Puerto Rico
um I found this like cool place
um and then I'll look forward like three
months we'll just book it and then I'll
show up and this is what I always do and
then you know if I'm going to be in
Puerto Rico I'll message like three
friends who are in Puerto Rico to like
see them as well
um yeah now what I've also done is I I I
encouraged my friends to move in with me
even when I had a one bedroom apartment
there were five of us living in the one
bedroom apartment and I would literally
pay for people to break their leases
and so if I and so if I do not need to
work on speechify there's a bunch of my
favorite people already in the kitchen
and then we'll go work out or go and run
or hang out or do whatever
so uh that camaraderie that you get in
college of the dorm room took me a long
time but I revived it for myself and
really what I want to do is like build a
compound where all my siblings live and
all my friends live and we all live on
one street and each person has a house
like that's gonna happen that's a dream
yeah
Brandon has this and he's eyes amazing
Utah yeah well all this from Jimmy has
this too yeah
um
yeah so so so so it's really great and
yeah that's the move
okay more specific questions on this so
how do you do you try and maintain inbox
zero on email iMessage WhatsApp messages
all that like I I have zillions of
whatsapps I need to reply to I always
feel like oh about it so I had a CEO
coach Matt macherry for the first two
years yeah I've read this thing I think
you linked to me his stuff absolutely
yeah I've been through his whole Google
doc it's incredible yeah yeah he's
amazing
um Matt loves inbox zero he has a bunch
of like rules for being a CEO
um I tried to maintain inbox zero uh for
two weeks and I got physically ill like
I literally got sick and Matt was like
okay don't do it
um and so every person has a different
way and style of working right I
definitely do because I have ADHD and I
have dyslexia I have a neurodiverse
brain and every person learns a
different way every person has their own
strengths and so one key that I tell
people who are working on companies is
like design your workflow to allow you
to work on the things that are your zone
of genius and have the team work on
everything else and you know we've
talked about this a bunch more
um
and so uh no definitely not on email
um I have the philosophy where if I
missed your email if it's important
you'll email me again
typically that's true for iMessage it's
more personal so I do make sure that I
respond to all the iMessages and so that
you know does and that's not very hard
because you can just heart something you
can leave an audio message like iMessage
is easy WhatsApp is relatively easy I
leave groups on WhatsApp as quickly as I
can uh the only group I'm in WhatsApp is
for my team and for my family uh because
I could care less what a random person
who is like a second connection says I
don't want that to filter I don't read
the news yeah all my knowledge comes
from like reading history and philosophy
um
yeah that's my workflow around uh those
kind of things and then you know the
other inbox on Instagram is also really
valuable because you'll get a lot of
inbound and there's no obligation to
respond but if something really good
pops up I'll respond
um
do you use WhatsApp archiving to
maintain in book zero no absolutely yeah
no no I I I don't archive on email I
don't archive on WhatsApp I don't
archive on iMessage
um I just let it flow and then if it's
important it comes back I do on email uh
star things and then every month or so
I'll go on the stars and I'll go look
through and I'll go what's important
that I missed it
90 of those things a month later they're
not relevant and not important anymore
yeah but really like
unless you're working for like 9-1-1 or
the police nothing's actually urgent if
it's important they'll message you again
that's it hmm
and then when you're sending these cold
DMS and stuff you'll be like oh hey you
know I loved your thing but whatever
um are you free on Thursday for Zoom 4
pm kind of vibes uh do you have a slot
in your calendar where it just happens
to be free or is it is it not like sorry
I'm addicted to iCal addicted my day is
like fully blocked the entire time
if this week is October 1st
uh I'm probably booked for the next
three weeks yeah so I looked at you know
October 25th 26 27th those days are
pretty free so I'll just suggest two
times on the 26th and two times four
weeks out yeah I just scheduled four
weeks out yeah by the way I did this in
college like during the summer I think
whoa this guy Dan shibler is awesome
he's like the captain of the MMA team
and he's also like a pre-med and he's
also taking a bunch of Cs classes
but I actually don't know him really
well hey Dan
signed the CIT the other day realized I
don't know you as much as I want to I'd
like to get to know you better are you
free to grab lunch in the ratty
um you know I know school is going to
start September 1st September 2nd at
noon
yeah happy too boom calendar in my scent
nice and so I do the same thing with
Founders without everybody I just
schedule four weeks in advance
nice and then when it comes to on the
day do you not feel like I've got this
Zoom call like do you ever get that kind
of thing because they don't schedule
things I don't like okay so the other
thing is like internally in the team too
like
uh the recruiting team works you know
around the clock with a lot of urgency
and uh I do not allow anybody to put
time on my calendar uh I put all the
time on my calendar so send me introduce
me over email to someone and I will
suggest to them a time that I want to
meet them yeah um and if we agree on the
time of the email then yeah please send
me a calendar invite or I'll send it to
you but take it quickly faster than
everybody else I have a keyboard
shortcut on my phone and on my computer
for my zoom link and so I just go boom
30 minute meeting Cliff plus Ali no you
know uh asterisk Z outfit autocomplete
the zoom link put in your email done I'm
waiting for your and if you don't accept
I expect that the event is not happening
and then if I see same day you didn't
accept it's a question mark instead of a
tag I'll be like Hayley be good for
three anyways yeah done
solid
it sounds so easy it actually is one of
the things I loved about your um last
time we spoke you said something like
tree treat airports as if the train
stations yes talk to me uh so the the
quote is I treat the airline system like
it's the subway system
I book All My Flights day of
almost entirely um when I was in college
I was like oh if I get three credit
cards I get like 150 000 points so I got
all the points
um and was responsible with the credit
cards never go into credit card debt
kids
um
it's a Valentine and I like booked this
great trip to like Hawaii with her
um and you know later when I started
spending money on ads I had a lot of
points
um and so I I do treat my calendar very
dynamically I'm making it sound like I'm
more richer than I am not
um I if if I'm really excited about
someone I will suggest because tomorrow
your calendar is not booked back to back
to backpack you have two free thoughts
and so if I saw someone awesome on this
podcast that I listened to today I'll
just so okay Ben Wilson from how to take
over the world I finished his entire
podcast in like three days
I've had him on Instagram and Twitter I
messaged him on both and I was like hey
I love what you wrote here one of my
biggest problems in knife in life right
now is I have a team that's 120 people
we've got 23 million users and I feel
like I'm not ambitious enough I want to
be way more ambitious than I am and what
I loved about your podcasts is you
extract why and how these people were so
ambitious I'd love for you to coach me
on how to be more ambitious are you free
for a call 3 P.M or 5 p.m on Friday I
set this on a Wednesday and he said yes
I was like sweet what's your email boom
calendar it might send
um but if I was not that excited about
William Wilson but I was like you know
eight out of 10 excited I would invite
him for like next month
um typically I try to invite for you
know three four days but like if it's
meeting someone in LA and I know I'll be
in LA in a month I'm not gonna be there
right now then I'll invite them for when
I'm gonna be in that place in person
[Music]
um
yeah I mean that sounds great like I
I feel like
yeah so I mean currently there's like
two people in Portugal that I know I
want to hang out with Paul Millard and
Peter levels
um and I've been thinking
I should just go to Portugal at one
point just hang out with them in person
and it'd be great to have them on the
Pod and like we could do remotely but
like it would just be fun to do it in
person and stuff and then and then I
keep on thinking oh but I look at my
calendar and it's like yep that was um
book and actually four weeks out it's
probably empty and I could just but I I
guess in my mind I'm thinking I couldn't
possibly schedule something four weeks
out wow and that's just a bit dumb
because I could schedule things a year
out yeah
um
Princess Beatrice is uh is dyslexic and
so she messaged me
I don't know like two months ago being
like hey I'm working on this thing you
know I love your product blah blah blah
and I was like oh I'll be in the UK in
two months you want to meet at this
place at this time she was like yeah so
you just booked a time I was messing
with JK Rowling's team because I'm
trying to get Harry Potter on speechify
as an audiobook we booked it for like a
month and a half two months out
um and then the day comes you can adjust
like you're not like gone to your head
and married to the time that you if
something comes up you go forward you go
backwards you go the next day it's fine
but like once it's on the calendar the
intention is set yeah
um I've had many time like I was gonna
meet someone I'll give you an extreme
example we had a teammate who wanted to
leave
someone offered him more money uh
actually that was not exactly the case
whatever he was gonna leave
he was based in Ukraine
I was like no no I want you to stay I
couldn't convince him I booked a flight
and I showed up in Ukraine like two days
later and then we went to the gym
together we did a bunch of things like
it was literally under martial law when
I went uh but I was gonna keep this
person on the team
um yeah and he stayed with us it was
great and then I was like oh you know
I'm in Ukraine I might as well go visit
my friend in Beijing and so I just flew
to China and then I was like oh I'm here
I'm gonna do a bit of turkey so I went
to you know hang out with a friend there
and then I went here then I went back to
California
um and so yeah it's all kind of very
Whimsical lackadaisical most meetings
you can move uh I okay so the thing I
was going to say earlier is you want to
work inside of your zone of genius and
never step outside of your Zona genius
and so one of my zone of Genius things
is I'm really good real time live like
high pressure environments are going to
shine and so I try to put myself in
those things as much as I can and if I
have an opportunity to go full force
into my Zona genius I will clear my
calendar and I'll go full force yeah
um and so sometimes that means going and
leading like the web monetization team
on a project or we're working on this
like really big project with like Tech
talk and Facebook right now on
acquisition so like I I will move other
meetings to make sure that I can make
those meetings happen
um and you know that's really really fun
another example by the way is you know
um uh Tyler messaged me and you in a
group chat like two days ago being like
hey you know I'm gonna go to Paris you
know this day to meet someone I'll lead
you want to join yeah
um and you know great let's hang out
like we know we're gonna go to Paris
awesome I know Thomas is there in
Matthew let's go hang out with them too
um and so
yeah like making plans is like just
super Dynamic and if it doesn't work out
it doesn't work out just make sure you
communicate well
um and you know we're gonna be in Paris
there's actually these two other people
who I really like in Paris let me DM
them and be like yeah I'll be in Paris
at this time you want to you know boom
there you go
um
I love that that's so great
okay so okay so I got this message by
the Paris thing and I was thinking okay
I'd love to go to Paris with these guys
but then I'm thinking okay but it would
be cool to go with my girlfriend and
that involves coordinating her calendar
because she works and it's like and then
coordinating my calendar and figuring
out like when we've got if we've got
podcast bookings and stuff and it it in
my mind it ended up being like so much
friction that I was like I'll deal with
this later because it was like at night
time and I haven't gotten around to
dealing with that yet because it
involves looking at my calendar and
sifting through the the mess of
coordination and stuff do you get that
like how do you no I don't yeah so
here's why not
Tyler goes hey it's gonna be October 6th
I look at October 6th am I is there
something in October 6 that is not
movable yeah if it's not the case I will
move everything on October 6th and I'll
go do the very fun thing that I want to
do yeah
um I'll call my girlfriend I'll text my
girlfriend at the moment or call her and
be like hey we want to go to Paris at
this date are you free this day if he's
not I'll then why don't you free cool
you're free here hey Tyler can you do
this date and if he says yes fantastic
if he says no Then you know then I need
to choose do I want to go to Paris
without my girlfriend actually it'll be
a day trip so yeah yeah why not
um one thing I love doing is I book
other people applies for them all the
time so chaitu who joined our team at
speedrify he had just finished working
on another company
um he was in India we had a great call
we were considering working together I
was like oh I really want to work with I
called him back I was like Hey too uh
when's your birthday cool okay I'll book
you a flight to LA from India uh uh
leaving this time of the state and I
checked with him ahead of time like you
know if he was free so he came and then
he just didn't leave the United States
like he just moved in with us and we
started working together
um I had a friend who was sampar who was
organizing this uh basketball thing
and and Duke uh would like uh Alex who
used to coach uh Kobe Bryant one-on-one
and now coaches Kyrie Irving and so we
organized this basketball weekend and so
I messaged like Ben Wilson I messaged to
me I was like yeah we talk about it
um and so you know we just organized a
bunch of friends and we just like did a
basketball clinic for a weekend and then
we went like other awesome people like
Hassan Minaj came and like whatever and
like it was completely random you know I
think you know the plan came together
maybe like three days before the thing
actually happened sweet cool I did it
for two days I flew down to North
Carolina flew right back to New York you
know that's it and I had a couple
meetings there I just moved them like
three days forward so I could do the
thing that I wanted to do and like
that is the thing that gives me energy
so I always just you know Vibe check is
this the thing that is going to give me
the most energy to do this day yeah and
if the answer is yes great that's the
thing I should do that day
so great so simple yeah I feel like in
my mind I really over complicate the
hell out of the scheduling stuff and
then and then like yeah you're right
like most things can be moved yeah and
so like there's so little that is
immovable now you and me have a freedom
that most people don't have which is we
don't work a nine to five job you know
you don't need to ask your boss for
permission to fly to Portugal but hey
most people listening to this I bet
you're still working remotely
um or you're a student if you miss a
class it's not a big deal you know how
many classes I missed in college or to
go and do like a hackathon or
competition like in Boston or London or
Ferris or whatever
um I once missed the midterm
um I just convinced him to like let me
take it on another day
because someone invited me to this cool
event that was gonna happen the next day
so yeah so I booked my flights you know
they have
um
and that's it
and so you know what do you need to get
to this one ideally you so okay I'm like
ridiculously Frugal I remember when I
moved to San Francisco
um I did not buy food for like the first
like week I like literally started being
hungry because lunch in San Francisco is
like 25 and I was like there's no way
I'm paying 25 for the Pokeball
but in the end I was like cool I gotta
not look at prices when I buy food here
um and so I made a rule I will not look
at prices when I buy protein in high
quality food I'm not gonna like ball out
at some like fancy restaurant I have no
interest in that it doesn't give me
utility but like I need to eat you know
200 grams of protein a day
um and then I didn't go to events
because I didn't want to pay for the
Ubers I would like a longboard like an
hour to get there and then I made a rule
I will not look at the price when I book
an Uber if it means I'm gonna hang out
with friends because it's important for
my well-being yep and then I
extrapolated that rule two planes once
it was reasonable to do so financially
um I extrapolated the same thing to like
buying gifts for people like if I saw a
hoodie that I think you'd really like I
will buy this hoodie or like these
headphones or whatever like if I can see
that something I can see is like
uniquely great for I why not just do it
um if I can with a small period of time
significantly increases someone else's
quality of life just do it like don't
even think about it just do it like make
it into a muscle into a habit right
somebody throws a ball at me I'm gonna
catch it
if there's a way for me to help you and
it doesn't I'm just gonna do it same
thing for booking an event that's going
to make me happy
um and then if I can't do it that's fine
like no one's gonna kill me I just
readjust and communicate as
appropriately yeah that's it
that's it damn that's so good I love it
um do you do you have any other sort of
uh tricks tips hacks principles
strategies that you use on the
relationships fronts to put more love
into the world thousands so first of all
uh Cliff Weisman on YouTube I've got
like a ton of videos on this on
Instagram on medium Etc
um yes there's a lot um
smiling stranger is really important
um just don't be afraid of other people
so so okay
no one will get mad at you for asking to
hang out no one will get mad at you for
asking to hang out and if they're busy
they just happen to be busy so you're
allowed to follow up like people are
like stressing out so much about double
taxing people who cares if you double
text people you are an awesome amazing
human being the fact that someone else
is busy has nothing to do with your life
like if you tried to message me during
this basketball weekend I was playing
basketball like I didn't have time to
see the message it's not that I don't
love you I just didn't look at my phone
um and so there's no problem in double
texting or 5x emailing especially if you
haven't met the person before they don't
owe you anything is it typically I am
willing to message someone like eight
times before they respond and I have
never had someone ever message me saying
stop messaging me Etc just be polite be
respectful
um
and don't get like hurt when you don't
get a response when the person has no
obligation to respond to you
um and so that's really important
removing that fear is key
when I was in college I made a list of
all the people who I thought were really
cool at Brown who I was not friends with
yet and I messaged all of them and I was
like hey you want to go to the gym
3 P.M on Monday most people said yes why
because everybody wants to go to the gym
everybody would love someone to keep
them accountable and now you have an
hour together where you're doing
something together next to each other
you're going to talk and so whether it's
coffee lunch or dinner Everybody Eats or
going to the gym like all those things
you're allowed to ask someone to do and
like it's so easy for them to say yes
and they're repeatable too like my best
friends in college were just people who
were my gym buddies
um because that's what we did and
actually you know when I moved here the
first thing you and I did was we we went
through we did a workout yeah and then I
happened to be going to a show and you
know the West End so you join us for the
show and then we realized that both of
us really like making music so we
started making music together it doesn't
matter what it is
um so just find an excuse and then I
will say that the other thing that I do
is I always look to spend time with
people who are going to make me better
right so you know if this person has you
know written a book that I admire or
they're a really good musician or
they're a good athlete or they're just
like a kind human being my best friend
in Palo Alto is this guy uh
Nick Hunter he used to be the captain of
the Michigan gymnastics team and he he
paints and he makes music
um you've never heard about Nick Hunter
but he's like the best human being I
know and like he's just a really good
friend and I grew so much by spending
time with Nick Hunter and like his
roommate was like a really good Jujitsu
coach and so you know Benji taught me a
bunch of stuff and you know it's just
fine people who are like genuine who are
like drunk on life just passionate and I
just look to surround myself with those
people and then if I run into people who
are not like how's your day going okay
why only okay oh nobody ever asks you
know this happens so there's
um there's a Instagram page Facebook
page called humans of New York and so if
you read a bunch of the posts you can
reverse engineer what the questions are
so I have this list of questions that I
ask people right you know uh what's your
can I ask you a personal question sure
what's your biggest struggle enough
right now what's your top three goals in
life what gives you energy in your work
um all these things and you get to like
the meat of the person and so in all
those dinners around three dinners a
night for two months
every semester
I just got really good at skipping over
the small talk and immediately going to
the big talk and the easiest way to do
that is you form relationships with
people either you Bond over ambition or
you Bond over vulnerability and so if
you're able to share that you were you
know I was bullied in like third fourth
fifth grade really badly someone slapped
me on the face in the middle of class
um you know I was bad at reading when I
was young
um I was really small like all all the
stuff
um
I had an accident whatever it might be
minhaj talked to me about this we talked
about how in comedy uh you know you want
to make a statement about something
um and if you can go low as opposed to
going high and go low status that's
really powerful it's actually very very
attractive if you're able to share
something vulnerable people gravitate
towards you
um and so if you can figure out what are
the things that You're vulnerable about
but that you're willing to talk about
that's really great
um right you and I I think at a certain
point we talked about how you're looking
for a wife and I was like oh that's
interesting tell me more about that yeah
I was put it over the whole like
systematizing relationships and yeah I
was I was single and I was like oh tell
me more and then you know we we nerded
out over you know yeah being bad with
Mean Girls
um and you know I have so many friends
who like struggle with the same thing
um I don't have kids but one day I would
love to have kids I want to have seven
kids
um man I love meeting friends who have
kids and like talking to them about what
it's like to be a parent like I just
again I read all the parenting books
ahead of time
um right so Bond over vulnerability Bond
over ambition
and there's a million things like this
amazing Cliff I think this is a good
place to end the part one of the
conversation
um we are still sort of in our timeline
it's still around 2015 so you're still
at University you haven't graduated and
you haven't started speechify full time
so uh part two definitely you'll would
love to have you in the new house uh
we'll still grab dinner we'll once we
set up our podcast dude in the next
couple of weeks it would be amazing to
do a part two where we Deep dive into
speechify and the story around that and
the Richard Branson staff and like all
of the all of the cool that you're
that you're doing
um thank you so much for this it's been
great so far um have you got any asks
for the audience you might have seen or
watched or listen so far
good question number one check out
speech of five speechified.com or
speechify on any of the app stores
number two if something sucks about
speechify let me know I'll fix it uh we
just launched audiobooks on speechify
and so if you message me about that I'd
appreciate it and you know we make a lot
of ads on Facebook Instagram take that
on YouTube and I'm trying to hire
comedians to help me write better ads so
if you are a small Creator and you
think that you can make as good ads or
write comedy for the ads hit me up also
I just moved to London and I'm looking
for a videographer so if you're a
videographer in London let me know I'd
love to hire you That's it man amazing
thanks for having me on the Pod thanks
all right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye